إذن هذا هو منتزه الشاحنات الرئيسي الذي
يمكنك رؤيته طوال طريق العودة إلى هذا الطريق بقدر ما
تستطيع رؤيته وقد
توقفوا جميعًا هنا طوال الطريق إلى
هناك وأثناء مرورك هنا
ترى أن هناك نفس الشيء على  هذا
الجانب على طول الطريق بقدر ما تستطيع
رؤيته وعلى طول الطريق إلى هناك، لذا فإن ما
ننظر إليه هو مهزلة مطلقة
لأنني أود أن أقول إننا ذهبنا للتو إلى قافلة الركاب التي
تعبر هناك قد تكون هناك شاحنة واحدة
نمر كل ساعة وهناك
2.3 مليون شخص يعانون بالفعل من
نقص الغذاء الوقود والدواء
ووصول المساعدات الإنسانية هو مجرد
حق أساسي للأشخاص في الصراع وقد
تم حرمانهم منه أه لذا ما يمكننا فعله
هو لفت الانتباه إلى هذه
الكارثة الإنسانية أه  والدعوة إلى
هذا
الظلم